[Electronic Music]
GENEL: I grew up with an 80% loss of hearing.
This has not prevented me from doing many activities in my life.
Being an entrepreneur gives me so much freedom
In determining what I want to do.
So I saw that I could do something about accessibility
In the field of communication for the benefit of hearing impaired.
RogerVoice is an application for deaf people
Make phone calls.
The idea of ​​the program is very simple.
Voice recognition is used
To record what the other party is talking about
And then you can read what he says.
The reason was not just the search for solutions.
But I was looking for something to take advantage of personally.
Then I realized there was a much easier solution.
I realized immediately that I had to do it in my favor
Lots of other users.
My goal was to provide as much access as possible
For everyone.
I know that Android has the broadest reach,
As it attracts today a billion users, a truly huge number.
As there are no obstacles in Android,
Which did not make me have to ask myself
Whether this is possible or not.
Then I decided to start it,
It was the beginning.
I had no skills,
I could not place code or designs.
I needed to find people and skills.
I knew then
I can do a lot,
But I needed the support of everyone
To accomplish it.
CHILEO: When Oliver spoke to me,
We initially decided to rethink mobility,
Now we can design an application based on accessibility.
I wanted to make something clear
Easy in terms of use, has helped me multidimensional design a lot,
Since all these guidelines were clear and easy.
Gryzbowski: We were able to update the versions of the application very easily,
Our oral application development took us three months.
GENEL: It was a wonderful moment when the application was designed.
You feel great happiness, I say
"Finally, I can call my mother."
I spent 24 hours after contacting all my friends
around the world.
Before launching the product,
I have been allowed the Google Play program and the demo program
I invite people to experience the application.
There were people in Canada who were experimenting with this application.
And others in Kuwait as well.
There is a person in Japan.
Balka: The application is not like the game
Which you can repair when it is malfunctioning.
It is supposed to provide an experience to change the meaning of life
In a person with an auditory impairment.
It would have been very frustrating if the result had not been satisfactory.
Therefore, thanks to the experimental use program,
We have been able to adjust the track since the launch of the public offering.
Griesboski: The most important thing I could get
In the RogerVoice application on Android
That I can create something useful and great benefit
Users.
GENEL: I feel that when you create something,
You have completed the required.
But then I realized that when you rethink it,
You'll find it still
There are many expected accomplishments.
I now see a big leap in accessibility
As an essential component of design and design.
I am also proud to be involved in this great progress.